test all right everybody
Welcome uh to the colloquium on
sustainability marketing and uh thanks
for coming out uh this is a fantastic
crowd we've got uh welcome to everyone
online as well who's watching from
different corners of the US and uh
around the globe everybody here in the
room is looking for the cameras they're
they're high above your head in the new
building of the School of Management um
my name is steuart Du the program
director at the Yale Center for business
in the environment which is a joint
initiative between the School of
Management and the school of Forestry
and Environmental Studies this series is
sponsored um or brought to you by the
Yale Center for business environment and
the Yale Center for customer insights uh
who where are we can people raise their
hands I'm missing Heather yeah great so
um this is really kind of a wonderful
collaboration for us to to work between
two centers uh that are both working at
the school of management and across
campus on a topic that that really
engages um a bunch of different
professional schools and gets people uh
you know quite excited so we've really
enjoyed the partnership uh we've had a
fantastic sponsor for this series uh
decra uh Anastasia oror who's in the
audience right there is actually uh sort
of the lead consultant uh who's working
on building out dec's sustainability
practice uh in the US and she's an FES
grad uh got her PhD from the school and
is local so if anybody needs a resource
that's on sustainability who knows a ton
about this and is working in the field
Anastasia's right here to to talk to
after the after the talk as well also
like to thank our media partner for this
uh so if anybody follows sustainable
Brands you'll see that they send
announcements about these talks
summaries about them uh to a wider group
of people um so thanks to sustainable
Brands uh for helping us distribute
these talks uh the title of today's talk
is Fat Tire slim foot slim footprint
crafting sustainable beers and brands
it's a discussion of sustainability
motivations initiatives and messaging in
the craft brew industry now um I've I've
been around here for about six years and
a I was a student at School of
Management the school of Forestry and um
now I've been an administrative role for
three years and we've hosted a lot of
talks during that period of time and so
I said when we sent this notice out I
got more responses to this um from
alumni or other people that I've
connected to than anyone else any other
talk that we've had saying you know you
finally put your stamp on the program or
something along those lines or I never
cared about sustainability before until
you finally sent me this you finally
figured out a way to make me like engage
or get excited about this topic so you
know when we talk about this series and
how you can inspire people to think
about this through the brands that they
love I think that that really hits on
that message that there's a universality
uh to this topic and the product that
we're going to discuss or the product
type that we're going to discuss that
really gets people uh excited personally
I can still remember as a college
student the first time I had Fat Tire
beer and how it opened my eyes to A
Whole New World of non- Miller Light
that had changed my pallet so uh it was
really an incredible experience so I'm
excited to hear this talk um uh the last
people that I'd like to thank for this
really um the people in the audience and
people online uh students have really
generated LED and pushed this as a focus
for the School of Management in the
school of Forestry they've done a
fantastic job with it uh the two student
leaders of it that have led this from
the beginning um Marissa and Laura have
done an incredible job another um
student leader Rachel has also been a
huge resource I'm going to invite
Marissa gesia down here to introduce our
speakers and introduce a little bit more
about the
talk hi everyone I'm Marissa galizia I'm
a joint degree student here at the
school of management and the school of
Forestry and environmental studies thank
you Stuart and thank you everyone for
being here today um um as Stuart
mentioned I'll just Echo his um
excitement to have our speakers here
today and for this um very both fun and
interesting topic of craft brewing um
Chris O'Brien is uh the author of
fermenting Revolution how to drink beer
and save the world he Chronicles the
evolution of beer focusing on how the
Renaissance of craft brewing and home
brewing over the last two decades is
making beer a more communal healthful
and sustainable practice once again um
and it has been said that his book turns
beer drinkers into beer activists by
providing an action plan for how to
drink beer and save the world so
hopefully all of you will go out and
beer be beer activist after this as well
um since 2009 Chris has served as the
Director of sustainability at American
University previously he directed The
responsible purchasing Network at the
center for a new American
dream um and earlier served as managing
director of the green business Network
and the Fair Trade Federation he is
treasurer of the fair trade Resource
Network and co-own the Seven Bridges
organic Brewing Supply
Cooperative Jen vervier uh started on
the bottling line at New Belgium
brewering company when 20 years ago she
became New Belgium Brewings first Chief
Financial Officer and later Chief
Operating Officer as the Director of
sustainability and strategy her
responsibilities include the
sustainability management system
corporate responsibility reporting
greenhouse gas accounting natural
resource management legislative advocacy
and philanthropy quite a lot um as
director of strategy Jen oversees New
Belgium strategic planning process
public private Partnerships and property
development so to those of you online
please feel free to engage via chat um
or or to tweet at us at Yale cbay we
will have an audience Q&A after the
session and we would love to take your
questions that way then and with that
I'll hand it over to Chris to kick the
session off thank you both thanks thanks
very much Stuart and Anastasia and
Marissa um by that introduction it makes
it sound like I have done a lot but
really I just drink a lot of beer so
things like this are what I need to keep
doing in order to justify that so so
thanks everyone for organizing this um
so um I'd like to just learn a little
bit about uh what you all do at New
Belgium I've obviously um drank I've
been drinking your beer for a long time
um had a similar experience to Scott you
know the first time I drank it um it
just kind of pulled me into the to the
Beer um but I've always had an an
orientation toward sustainability um and
so I'm curious if you can tell us a
little bit about how New Belgium Brewing
sees sustainability as part of its
corporate identity if it does um and and
what you know some of the evolution of
of how the company sees sustainability
sure um yeah so our co-founders started
the company back in 91 at the very
beginning of the craft beer um
Revolution as you call it um and before
they even started selling any beer they
went for a hike in Rocky Mountain
National Park to determine what kind of
company they wanted to create what their
core values would be and they came up
with four of them one of which was to be
environmental stewards so for New
Belgium that's been baked into our
identity from the very beginning and now
20 some years later we have a purpose
that all of our co-workers Orient around
like why do we come to work every day
and the reason that we say that we do is
to manifest our love and talent so our
passion and our Excellence by creating
our customers favorite Brands as well as
by proving that business can be a force
for good so we are motivated by the
challenge of how can we be commercially
successful financially successful and
still live according to our values
so you've worked for the company for 20
years I'm curious at what point was
sustainability incorporated into a job
position it sounds like you were the
first person in a position with
sustainability in the title and how what
was the thinking that led to that and
just tell us a little bit about you know
what what's the dayto day of being a
sustainability director at one of the
country's biggest craft breweries um we
actually had sustainability staff folks
before I had my position and
interestingly they that job started out
in the marketing department um because
it was around answering customer
inquiries giving chours serving on
nonprofit boards things like that and
then it moved over into environmental
health and safety which is another place
where you see sustainability live when
you're talking about uh waste reduction
and net you know Net Zero goals um and
then so when we created the executive
level position to start getting strategy
around sustainability we realized that
everything we had done to that date
would be was because people were really
passionate and very conscious but to
secure our Legacy we needed to create a
sustainability management system and set
strategic goals as important as our
goals around our financials or how we
show up in the marketplace um so in my
job I'm looking I'm working with a
natural resources management team on how
to improve our efficiencies um we have a
very robust philanthropy program where
we give a dollar for every barrel of
beer that we sell to nonprofits so for
2013 that'll be close to $800,000 that
we give to nonprofits that are
strategically aligned with our mission
um and then as Merissa mentioned
political advocacy how can we move the
needle in policy to enable
sustainability to be more likely and you
know more more um feasible so it sounds
like at least in terms of the
positioning within the company it moved
from starting out being part of how you
tell the story moving towards
environmental health and safety which I
think you know on the surface of it
makes sense and is now something that
really sounds like it's more woven into
the strategy of the company as a whole
exactly right yep and um and really the
motivation for that would just be that
so to make sure that one that we're
walking our talk and that we continue to
be true to what we believe in because it
because it has to be intentional and it
has to be woven out through obviously
you know through the supply chain
through the value chain operations and
and how we show up in the
marketplace and so in your role with
both strategy and sustainability how how
are those two part of the same or you
know how why are they related um I think
that I've been able to bring my
sustainability perspective to some of
the things that we do in strategy um
like uh you know a strategic project is
site selection so we have to build we
have to build another Brewery because
we're running out of capacity so how do
we choose the location for that that is
the most least impactful or you know
helps us achieve our sustainability
goals I know in in the uh run up to the
this event um the organizers were
looking to get some fat tire or other
beers from New Belgium to be available
at the happy hour and they couldn't find
any locally so I think there'll probably
be a lot of people celebrating once that
new Brewery is open what any Target date
can so we're in um 36 States so it's not
just Connecticut that we haven't we
haven't gotten to yet but um we are
breaking ground on our Brewery um in May
and we'll be selling beer out of it in
2016 okay project and that it's in North
Carolina North Carolina on a Brownfield
site okay right on the in the River
District uhhuh great um so is New
Belgium do you think New Belgium is
unique or is there something you does
does the craft beer industry uh you know
I know your owner has has served on the
Brewers Association board for a long
time um it from that vantage point do
you see sustainability as something that
the craft beer Community or movement as
a whole Embraces um or is there
something um sustainable about craft
beer as as a product or as a um as an
experience or is it something that seems
more unique to New Belgium I think that
um craft Brewers in general are very
environmentally conscious that it is a
sustainably aware community and we've
been uh thinking about why that might be
in conversations that I had today with
folks here at Yale and I think that that
craft Brewers are the ultimate conscious
consumers so I mean they're beer Geeks
to start obviously and then and and and
they're so passionate about their their
what they love that they think I need
I'm going to make it myself I can make
it better I care about my ingredients
therefore I know my suppliers in my
supply chain I care about doing the best
very best job possible in my operations
therefore I reduce waste and and
optimize the process I care about my
customers because they're my neighbors
and I care about my co-workers because
they're my neighbors and and so it's
very Community uh embedded and I think
being embedded in a local community is
um you know one of the
a Genesis for thinking about your
environment and wanting to preserve it
do you think those environmental and
sort of DIY values are reflected in the
customer base of craft
beer a lot of people drink craft beer so
which is a good thing so it's hard to
generalize um but yeah I think that
probably people who choose to drink a
craft beer over another beer are
similarly conscious consumers they care
about what they put into their body and
they make the uh they make the decision
to choose something that's a little bit
different or a little bit more
interesting it has has more of a story
to it than perhaps uh just pulling
something off the
shelf you mentioned that you think craft
Brewers are interested in being part of
their Community um I'm curious if you
think that to to me one of the things I
love about beer as a beverage is that it
seems inherently like a social beverage
it's something that typically brings
people together um anytime you have a
free beer happy hour it's going to bring
a lot of people out um but it really is
something that I think lends itself
towards being social and I'm curious if
you see that aspect of you know
Community Building as being something
that you view in tandom with
sustainability do you do you put those
two um Concepts do you think of them
together or are they kind of different
ideas not really related
um good leading
question um absolutely related you know
at certainly at New Belgium that
sustainability is a broader category
that doesn't just mean environmental
stewardship but also is how we um create
our culture and how the you know the
relationship that co-workers have to
each other so within sustainability for
New Belgium is you know that we're 100%
employee owned that we have a democratic
workplace um and that we have benefits
that people kind of bring their whole
self to work so because I think because
we're a corporation we turn think if
sustainability in terms of it's human
Centric so whereas you're just an
environmentalist you can think about
nature for Nature's sake but we have
maybe more of an instrumental view of
nature like how do we preserve a quality
of life worth living um and and that
aligns very well with craft beer right
craft beer is one of the things that
makes life worth living and so um and so
you know that and I think it it aligns
well with like the joy of being alive so
that's kind of what we try and
communicate so preserving natural
environments being able to have clean
water to make clean beer like all these
things are woven together into what
makes um what makes a good life so you
talked a little bit about making sure
that some of broadly speaking
sustainability values are part of the
intent of the company U but you also
talked about how sustainability was
originally part of the marketing
department so I'm curious how um what
has the experience been at New Belgium
integrating sustain ability into the
message to to customers right um well
it's it's certainly been an evolution
and I think it's still a matter of trial
and error and I have some images that
I'd like to share that how it's evolved
um and you know one of the things I
think we've realized is there are some
consumers of environmental data are
probably like all of us in the room or
many of us in the room like we want the
facts and the figures and we want to
drill down into the calculations and but
the majority of consumers of information
about New Belgium are just people who
like beer you know and so what is our
role in communicating to them how do we
communicate awareness to them about who
what New Belgium does to try and make
you know to bring about positive change
in a way that relates to beer because
we've found out over time that that's
probably a good thing to do so this is
an an an older commercial probably like
10 years old and you can see by the fact
that you can probably hardly even read
it that it has a lot of information on
it and this was one of our first foray
into quote quot environmental marketing
or environmental sustainability and the
top of it says somewhere at the top it
says you know that we're that we're in
New Belgium and we and we pollute so
that was sort of our way to avoid
greenwashing like to say right out like
we use natural resources full stop and
here are some of the things we're doing
to offset that that those impacts and
it's a lot of information and I'm not
sure if it drove anyone to buy our beer
or to buy more beer and ultimately our
advertising dollars have to do both you
know because we have philanthropy
and that can do philanthropy things but
advertising also needs to drive
consumption right um so then we went
through another phase of what we called
advocacy advocacy and advertising
combined and so we thought so um you
know one of the things you don't want to
do is talk brag about yourself it
doesn't come off very well um and so to
avoid that we had an advertising
campaign that featured other people um
which was really interesting probably
didn't sell any more beer and it um and
it didn't really have any relevance
didn't really tie back to relevance for
beer so the next phase on that was um uh
for a few years we had a summer beer
called beer called Skinny Dip um
excellent beer um and we tied that
campaign to water advocacy and so these
are actual things that happened um you
know this is like removing removing a
dam uh protecting a shore break in
Southern California like these were real
campaigns that we contributed to and we
would used our advertising to raise
awareness of these issues and then this
one our last the last year we had the
beer we tied it to um did you notice the
other one say save the rivers and this
says save the Colorado because we
initiated a um philanthropy campaign and
a partnership with other brands like
Patagonia and tea and Cliff to bring
consumer Brands together um not just to
give money to nonprofits who work in the
Colorado River Basin but as to use our
strength as a consumer brand to let the
30 million people who depend on the
Colorado River for drinking water know
that they do so um you know I don't know
how successful this was at selling beer
but it certainly was a fun campaign and
and tied to our
philanthropy
um for a long time this is one of the
challenges I'm sure that you guys talk
about in class but that people when you
Market something you want it to be
simple and sometimes that can be
inaccurate and so for a very long time
New Belgium said that we were wind
powerered because we subscribed to power
back in 1998 we Subs all of our
electricity we subscribed to the city's
wind power program we made a 10-year
commitment to pay the extra money for
that for that wind energy which enabled
our city to build another turban and a
grid tide turban so that was a real
thing that happened but over time the
city's uh green energy portfolio also
contained reck and when we said that we
were wind powerered I think folks
expected to drive up to the brewery and
see the wind turbines and so we just
felt like it was too that was um could
be seen as misleading to say that we
were wind powerered and so we abandoned
that tagline and picked up alternatively
empowered which is Broad and also brings
in the cultural piece about our
co-workers so this campaign was about
that again probably too much detail for
the average beer
consumer so this is a um post coaster
that we have out now which I kind of
like ends these are um these are our
this is an actual picture at the brewery
and these are methane storage balloons
we capture the methane from on-site
water treatment store it in these
balloons and then Pump It Back pipe it
back to the brewery to run into coens to
offset our Peak
power it it sounds like you're saying
telling people about sustainability
doesn't necessarily sell
beer I guess I should ask other people
if that's true or not but I think that
might be true do I mean do you think
that I mean it seems like it might
be a simple lesson really that I mean th
this picture maybe it's what you're
saying is telling them with a very
crowded list of accomplishments is one
thing but showing them in one image
tells the story for you without needing
to cram in a lot of complicated right
stats exactly is it is it elegant is it
engaging and is it succinct and and do
you think that this reflects the values
of of your customers to the degree that
it would drive sales well you know I
think it's tongue and cheek which I
think appeals to a beer drinking aged
consumer uhhuh
um yeah speaking of which the the the
beer drinking age consumer um in your
demographic is pretty tightly overlapped
with the Millennials um who have some
unique challenges as a as a group
because they don't really like to be
marketed to um they they can tell when
they're being told a story that sounds
phony um they want something authentic
so have you faced challenges uh related
to the sustainability message Mage with
Millennials not really wanting to hear
you know you mentioned greenwashing and
trying to avoid it have you ever felt
like well you know I guess the energy
example was was an example where maybe
would you have call in retrospect would
you call that
greenwashing no I think I had to believe
there's some intentionality to green
washing which there never was you know
um I think it was just maybe confusing
uhuh but with messaging to the
Millennials actually I think it's a
great opportunity for New Belgium
because I think our brand is spot on on
for Millennial messaging from my
understanding of it and the things that
we found out um you know Millennials are
very interested in the backstory of
their product so like we're were talking
about conscious consumers like who is
the company that is making the thing
that I buy and we have a great story we
like to present ourselves you know
through our branding and I think that
resonates um Millennials are very
interested in experiences they're not
passive consumers of of their media they
engage with their media you know
obviously with social media and uh I
think new belg pretty Adept at that
communication and that our message plays
well there MH I I thought that was an
interesting point about intention with
greenwashing and you know to talk about
marketing and
sustainability I think a question that
often comes up is where's the line
between what's greenwashing and what's
maybe simplifying a complicated message
and it seems to me like maybe that's a
good good rule of thumb that um an
intentional um overstatement of
accomplish
does that seem or or a simplification
where the truth is lost yeah I think and
that I think is what brings so much
complexity to marketing around
sustainability because they're not
simple issues you know which is better
can uh aluminum can or glass bottle well
it's just I can't answer that in one
word you know it's a complex issue with
life cycle assessments behind it but you
right so the challenge is distilling
that into something that matters to your
customer without losing the truth so
maybe do is are does your marketing
serve as as an entry point into deeper
information is there a lot more of this
available if I wanted to drill down and
learn about the the real right
nitty-gritty right which I think a lot
of brands are doing so if you want so uh
we want to Intrigue you and if you are
intrigued then you can go to the website
to find out more you know I think that's
that's the design of it and then you can
you can look at the front page and see
the very simple it and you can drill
further and further and see the
sustainability management system or the
life cycle assessment or I think that's
the way to communicate with folks but
that's not you've left the realm of
marketing and branding right at that
point right and you're now you're in a
research project I'm cheating a little
bit because I knew some of that answer
because I actually teach a class at our
business school at American University
on sustainable products and we just read
your LCA um if you haven't read it and
you're interested in lca's life cycle
assessments um the first one I ever read
you know talk about how do you bring
people to to an issue well you talk to
them about something they care about
apparently a lot of people care about
being beer when you come to a college um
so the first I I care a lot about beer
and I care a lot about sustainability so
when you guys did a life cycle
assessment of one of my favorite beers I
thought okay well I can get into the
details now because I care about the
product was it more as you read it you
were more interested because I could Rel
you're interested in hops you're
interested I knew the ingredients I knew
the packaging right so all all of the
decisions or the challenges that you
were facing as a result of understanding
the impacts of that product were things
that I could relate to as a customer
because I could then see oh um where
does new Belgium's responsibility end
and someone else's begin when you're
talking about open refrigerated units in
corner shops where you're air
conditioning a whole store but your
product is the cause of the air
conditioning but also my purchasing of
your product you know who who and if it
wasn't new Belgium's beer there
certainly it' be someone else's beer
there right right right so so speaking
of small Corner shops um you know the
craft craft breweries have been
metaphorically the small Corner Shop in
the beer industry in in North America
for 30 or so years now um edging up
towards maybe now 7% or so by volume
does that sound right of of beer beer
sold so still relatively speaking a drop
in the bucket of the overall industry
and yet um that's from almost zero 30
years ago to 7% now so I I'm curious how
New Belgium especially with opening new
Brewery soon sees that issue of scale
and how that relates to sustainability
and and the story of sustainability uh
how big is is too big or is there such a
thing um at what point might your story
have to change if you become you know
what are your sites for how big you want
to grow and how does that affect your
marketing of sustainability yeah and
that's a great question and and it was
one that occupied New Belgium alipus
internally for quite some time to grow
or not to grow is it sustainable to grow
and certainly we had folks inside on
both sides of the issue um and obviously
we made the decision to grow as you can
see and and the reason that we came to
that for a couple of reasons one as I
alluded to people are going to buy a
beer anyway and so if more people are
able to buy our beer and we're you know
investing in um sustainability and in a
great place to work you know like
they're that's putting people's money to
good use like we know if they buy our
beer then they're investing in a more
sustainable company so that's good for
one and then for two
um we are able to provide more
employment that's um you know more
meaningful for people so the more people
that we employ the more people have
meaningful work um and then thirdly we
saw it as a chance to provide
opportunity for people internally which
is a huge you know if you're a if you're
a 30 person Brewery and that's as big as
you're ever going to get then eventually
your best and your brightest are going
to leave and go to other careers and
other places to to stretch their wings
and find their talents but if we can
keep growing we can keep those people
inside and develop keep developing you
know our turnover rate is extremely low
and I think one of the reasons is
because we grow we can continue to
provide
opportunity so so so what you're doing
now is as a company is good and more of
that is better I think so what about so
last time I checked I think the the
numbers were something like one out of
every two beers in America was brewed by
AB inbev what what most people would
think of as Budweiser um which is
actually now the at least last time I
checked and this may have changed was
the largest global Brewing conglomerate
um owned by a Brazilian new Brazilian
Belgian um conglomerate no longer an
American-owned company but in any case
to the scale question is one and two to
too big you know or could you see a you
know is there a point at which scale
might compromise some core
value I don't think it has to um one to
is a bit of a thought experiment you
know but um uh you know one of the
things that we've charged ourselves with
part of the challenge for us is to prove
that you can grow and stay true to your
beliefs I mean that's the interesting
that's the interesting nugget there so
can we have two breweries and still have
the same culture or you know as good of
a culture in both can we be um H have
the pressures that larger companies have
and still stay true to our beliefs and
and going to 100% employee ownership um
at the end of 2012 I think for us was a
a huge hurdle in enabling that um to
secure our Legacy because succession
planning is real you know like the
turnover of capital has to happen and so
one of the options an obvious option was
to be bought by another Brewery that's
what aneis Bush did you know that's what
many craft Brewers are are having to do
and if we had gone down that route then
we would have lost control of our
destiny but by getting the financial
deal put together that we could sell to
our co-workers we have ensure that we
will be able to stay true to who we are
in perpetuity hopefully one thinks of
other brands Mission oriented Brands
like Ben and Jerry's uh or honesty which
um I had the occasion to um speak with
Seth Goldman the founder of honesty just
recently Who Sold honesty to to
Coca-Cola 100% it was a gradual sale
that resulted eventually in 100% um
another example is Cliff bar if people
know you know the the um energy bars um
the guy who started that company tells a
story where they were getting ready to
he was being whined and dined by big
companies about to walk into the
boardroom and sign the papers that's it
right and he the way he tells the story
it moves a whole room he he the way he
tells it is he had literally golden Pen
in Hand in a skyscraper in somewhere in
downtown New York City about ready to
sign a contract to sell his company and
he said he felt like he was about to
have a heart attack he went out went
outside to get some fresh air and he
never went back and as far as I can tell
um they're still independent today
that's true so it's obviously a you know
it's a discussion that people with a
mission um face that challenge and it
seems to me like putting ownership in
house maybe the solution yeah because
then you'll you you're as you grow the
decisions continue to be made by by the
owners of the business or the the
employees in your
case um you you've uh done some cool
speaking of mission oriented businesses
you've done uh at least one cool
partnership that that I know of um with
Patagonia can you tell us a little bit
about that yeah absolutely um so folks
of Patagonia have been friends with us
for a long time we are aligned you know
on a mission basis they contributed to
our save the Colorado River campaign and
we worked with them on that and so last
year they approached us for their um
40th anniversary to brew they asked us
if we would brew a beer for them for
their 40th anniversary which of course
we were honored to do and then as we
weren't through development with it um
we realized that we could align it with
the launch of it with um Black Friday
and you know a couple of years ago they
did that uh patagon did the full scale
ad in the Wall Street Journal in New
York Times said don't buy this jacket
which was a pretty great pretty great
campaign and so this was the next you
know Thanksgiving day after Thanksgiving
later that um they launched in their
stores that take uh that they're going
to start selling used Patagonia gear and
they're going to start taking it back in
certain stores and so um uh last summer
they came out to the brewery and met
with our Brewers and talked about what
kind of beer they wanted to drink and
what kind of beer they wanted to make so
we made an organic logger um and we had
no intention of of selling it but we had
extra and so you know we just made it um
available on a small scale so was that
mission alignment something that was
nice to have and it made it fun or if um
if Exxon Mobile came and said would you
brew a celebration beer for us I mean
you know really because after all it's
it's an employee owned company making
good beers that are sustainable so what
I'm curious you does the marketing is
the marketing alignment just a nice
thing or is it would it be a deal breal
absolutely essential yeah I mean you
know you have to protect your brand with
your life right because it is it is your
identity so so no we would never partner
with Exon I feel a commun Lally say that
we would never part reel um but we are
looking at so Patagonia was our first
non
brewery beer collaboration we've done
collaborations with many other breweries
across the US in the spirit of you know
collegiality and sharing just having fun
together in in the brew house so patagon
was our first non- Brewery collaboration
and we're and it was so successful and
it um people were so into it that we're
looking at doing more of those and we're
going to focus hopefully on doing it
with other B Corps other beneficial
corporations like Patagonia like pen
Jerry so other folks who have um gone
through the process of getting a uh
benefit Corp certification you know
third Pary third party independent
verification of that they're hitting
certain social environmental
sustainability goals that they've
changed their corporate charter to say
that they provide a public benefit so so
this is you know you you you you've come
back to this social element of you know
kind of community within the craft Pier
community of uh you know collaboration
beers with other breweries I'm curious
if um you know if that's is that another
thing where it's part of who you are or
it's just something that's nice in other
words where where does the where where
might you draw the line between friendly
collaboration and competition so for
example uh there's been you know for
beer Geeks like me I follow the the the
kind of In-House chatter and there's
been a recent controversy between um
relatively local Brewer here um the
Boston beer company and a company out on
the west coast has been challenging some
of the marketing tactics by that company
as being focused on competing with other
craft
Brewers well why wouldn't you comp you
know you're you want to sell more of
your beer but so it Market it implies
that there's some unspoken agreement
that it's us against them craft Brewers
against industrial Brewers is that true
or is there some kind of collegiality
that you won't you wouldn't want to
cross a line or ultimately is it selling
more of your beer right um our
experience and our belief has been that
um you know in the on the production
side the operation side Brewers
collaborate with Brewers people in the
labs collaborate with people in the lab
like that they're they're know they
scientists and they're engineers and
they love what they do and they love to
share it and that and we um encourage
that and it's a great part about being
in the craft brewing industry but once
you cross over to the sales and branding
then you're not collaborating anymore
you know then it is you're right it's
competition it's not it's pretty
traditional and I don't think and
anything that would be untour in any
industry would be that way in a crap F
industry but certainly selling a brand
and because I know what you're talking
about but selling a brand that's popular
and so that some other Brey also makes
at that brand that that's competition
uhhuh which I think is completely above
board and All is fair when it comes to
competition no not all but certainly
that was do you think that your that
that your customers would punish you if
they saw you as um not being one of the
gang within the craft beer
scene I think that most 99% of craft
beer consumers don't have the the
geekiness about it that you probably do
you know what I mean I don't think that
they they're just buying a good beer I
think they're not aware yeah they're
just buying a good beer they go to the
shelf and they say what looks
interesting to me either what what
packaging do I like what Brewery have I
heard of that I think is cool what
styles do I like what did I try the bar
that was cool and and you mean the the 0
one% Geer Geeks like me don't set the
expectations for everyone else we're not
not controlling the marketplace pastes I
always thought you're you are an
influencer okay thank you um well so the
the the million dollar question I
suspect at least for some people here
and then we'll open it up to questions
is um the first time that that I met you
was at the craft Brewers conference in
San Diego and it was very trying
circumstances because there were a
hundred craft beer taps of Southern
California beers at this conference and
this was after a day of waking up
tasting beers as part of the conference
at the end of the day at the hotel the
pool area was surrounded by a 100 Taps
of California beer um so how does
someone get a job like
this sustainability at a brewery do you
just drink beer all the time and save
the world right that's right it's pretty
awesome well so let let's open it up um
so I think we uh we have time for
questions and to ask a qu I'll try to
keep a cue um but to ask a question you
have to press a button that's in front
of you and hold it down U because we are
streaming right now uh so this is your
voice will be recorded um and when you
before you ask a question just say your
name and uh what and your
affiliation
questions hi I'm Carol Rosenfeld I'm a
second year MBA student here at the
School of Management thanks so much for
your talk and I wanted to go back to
your point about you know is growth
always good um I had the to see Seth
Goldman speak about honest te in the
fall and he said sort something similar
to what you said where he said um every
time somebody chooses Honest Tea instead
of soda they're making a good
sustainable decision and similar to what
you said about people are going to drink
beer anyway and I think I came away with
that a little bit cynical that people
might be choosing to drink water so how
do you deal with is is growth really
always good yes some people will always
be drinking beer but they could be
drinking something
else they could be home brewing they
could be home brewing well I think that
the consumer needs to choose that I mean
like like you as an individual citizen I
shouldn't just call you a consumer
you're also a citizen and if you um
believe that water is the more
sustainable Choice then you should make
that decision but as a brewer I present
my product you know you know what I mean
so and so we present it to the
marketplace and the marketplace will
side but I don't think that if New
Belgium had stayed at half its current
size there'd be more people drinking
water that would be that's my
belief other questions here and then
there hi my name is Devin I'm from North
Carolina and I have a site specific
question for you actually about your new
Brewery in Asheville basically how have
you engaged with a local community there
what were some of the decisions or what
were some of the details surrounding
your decision to locate there um what
are you going to to do to increase U
community involvement awesome um so well
we've done a lot around Community
participation in Asheville I I did site
selection for the brewery and then I
worked for several months on uh
community relations and um so choosing
the Asheville brewery was uh obviously
so many things went into that decision
around uh the availability and qual
quality of the water the economics you
know from land to labor to taxes to um
utilities you know the whole uh shipping
you know how would impact new Belgium's
uh shipping costs um and then the
cultural piece was obviously huge for us
we were looking for a site where uh our
co-workers and our customers could bike
to the brewery we didn't want to be in
an industrial park you know outside of
the Ring Road and um and we were also
hoping to find a Brownfield site because
it was important to us as part of
offsetting the impact of growth that we
would rehabilitate a former
manufacturing site rather than um
developing a green field so we don't
just grow you know I mean we don't we
not throw caution to the wind with
growth I mean we're are certainly very
conscious in the choices that we make so
so we were able to find all of those
things in Asheville as well as a very
sympathetic Community as far as um being
Progressive and interested in food and
interested in beer and renewable energy
and all the things that that we care
about as well and so throughout the
entire process we've engaged with
Community leaders um every every every
other month or so like all the the key
uh and there are a lot of neighborhood
associations in Asheville so the leaders
from those bring them in let them know
of our plans find out what their
concerns are work it into sort of anou
around our development um and as well as
go engage with the local Brewers to find
out what their concerns are with us
coming and and how we could M mitigate
that answer your
question hi good afternoon my name is
yenia and I'm a first year at the school
of Forestry um and first of all I think
you should collaborate with Yale and
make a craft brew for us um but my
question has to do
High Le
series um so my question has to do with
um your sourcing for your um your grain
or malt um and or Hops and I'm wondering
what sort of sustainability goals or
metrics you have around the agricultural
aspects of the brewing and if you have
any um if there's any movement towards
sourcing organically or if that's part
of your sustainability goals um I I do
recall you having an organic beer um and
if you could tell us a little bit about
how that exper went and maybe sort of
the future of the Organics if you're
going to go that route okay um so we did
at one for a quite a few years have one
organic brand and um and you know the
Organic certification and the cleaning
in between and the you to separate the
raw materials it we quickly realized
they you know in for a penny in for a
pound it would be easier to have
everything be organic than just one
brand and um there were limits to the
supply of organic bar barley we could
get and the quality of The Malt that we
would need to produce our beers as well
as the cost so all there a lot of things
not in favor of that and we looked at
the you know several million dollars at
that time it was quite a few years ago
that would be incremental cost we felt
like we could do um more impactful
things with it than buy organic
barley um but in our supply chain this
is one of those scale things we are not
big enough to know who our farmers are
like we buy our malt from maltsters who
buy from barley Growers so we don't have
that one toone relationship that a much
much bigger Brewery would be able to
have but we do have sustainable
purchasing guidelines that we engage
with our major engage our major
suppliers around so we will you know
score them on quality and price and
customer service as well as a whole
section on sustainability that it's
relevant to you know is it water use is
it waste reduction is it that they
participate in their with their industry
groups to improve the sustainability of
of their industry practices um so we we
try you know we we try to keep it a
dialogue with our suppliers to learn
about what their challenges are and to
suggest ways that would be meaningful
for us as their customer for them to
change their practices there as a
followup to that I know there are
there's at least one grower small scale
hop grower in Colorado right it and
maybe even near Fort Collins have you
been part of that no we did um
uh Finance we did support a program at
CSU to look at developing a hop industry
in Colorado so with the a extension like
what varieties grow here how do you take
care of them how do you help farmers
convert their fields but again it's a m
then it's the matter of scale in the
other direction like the amount of hops
that are grown outside of Fort Collins
would not even be one batch of beer
right for New Belgium you know so so
then we're then were're too big to take
advantage of that kind of scale but I'm
sure that many local local like just
sell right out of their Brewery Brewers
could take advantage of that do you
think that's in the cards sometime in
the future a more direct relationship
with suppliers either of of malt from
Growers that you might be able to
identify Upstream at at the at the at
the barley growing level or on on the
other side on the Hop level yeah I think
in a collaborative way like that we meet
with a Consortium of Growers and
certainly at the Hops we we know who
those Growers are CU they there are less
of them that Supply the industry I mean
I think that's industry that's
interesting hop growing in America is
changing because of craft brewing I
don't know if you've looked in your you
know Research into the supply chain it's
craft Brewers are making a a big mark on
what that industry looks like in the
Northwest uhuh in terms of varieties or
because of high hop beers that was you
know that wasn't true for so long there
was just certain amount of hops and a
certain variety of hops and that was
what went into um you know industrial
loggers and now the Hop Liberation is
intense right okay other questions one
two and then three
hi we have a few questions from the live
stream uh so the first one is from Sean
and his question is uh with breweries
focusing more on sustainability who
tends to respond to the sustainability
focus more is it older or younger aged
drinkers that as a great question and
I'm honestly I'm not sure um people who
are at universities doing research
projects they're the ones I talked to
the most but um uh I would have to
believe that
from you know our research that younger
drinkers care more about what they're
consuming and so they're the ones who
are most interested in the backstory
behind their
products all across the board not just
beer uh I'll just ask one more from the
live stream so our second question is
from Elanor and she has directed her
question to Jen Jen you mentioned
engaging on policy to make
sustainability initiatives easier why do
you think it's important for companies
to do that that's a great question um
you know I think that uh policy um
regulation kind of sets the Baseline for
behavior and that certain things you
know like uh carbon trading is an
obvious one carbon trading just doesn't
happen voluntarily unless there's
regulation to re reduce emissions no
one's going to take on the expense and
in the US that's a quite a bit of a
distant um Imagination that that that
will happen but you know more up close
we look at recycling so the
sustainability of our product is in part
determined by the Recycled content in
our packaging and New Belgium can't
determine how much recycled contents in
our packaging that's an industrywide
thing and so how do we increase the um
recycled content by there being more
recycled raw material more recycled feed
stock as it were and so when you look at
states that have a bottle Bill and they
have an 80 to 90% recovery rate and you
look at states that don't and they could
have a 0 to 10% recovery rate so that
feed stock is not available in states
without a bottle bill so that's just I'm
not saying that the bottle bill is the
best answer but it's an example of how
regulation creates the conditions to
improve sustainability in some
cases okay there was a question over
here um thank you for coming this
afternoon evening um my name is
Alexander and I'm a first year student
at the school of management and my
question is largely about the conflict
between P like fully sustainable
breweries and more local breweries that
maybe are not scalable yet to really
achieve this sustainability goals and um
at what point you see like that being a
large source of conflict with New
Belgium and when it um grew so that it
wasn't its own
issue um the conflict internally or
conflict with other breweries breweries
well we try not to engage in a conflict
based competition that we talked about
before but I certainly think that um the
people wanting to purchase locally is
obviously real and there's and there's
Merit in it
and New Belgium can't be local but in
you know two places eventually however
that being said I still think that the
cons it warrants the consumer to
consider buying a new Belgian beer over
a local beer just because of the things
that you said like because we're able to
give money in their local community
because we employ people you know in
sales and distribution and Retail in
their local community more than a very
very small Brewer can so I don't think
it's either or but I think that there
are things that a larger company that is
focused on um
on making positive change can do that's
maybe more impactful than a very small
very
could I just want to follow up on one of
the one of the things you mentioned a
minute ago um regarding you know the
availability of recycled content
material has to do with whether there's
a bottle bill in the state or not so I'm
curious if um if New Belgium has uh has
or would lend its voice to policy
advocacy that outside of policies that
might you know be obvious things that
would ease the um that would improve the
market for selling craft beer but things
that have more to do with sustainability
um on a with a sidebar there being to
note that the I don't know if it's
former or if he still is the governor of
Colorado owns a brew pub in downtown
Denver right and remind me he's still
the governor he had to sell his interest
in the Brew Pub we got into politics but
yes so politics he is a brewer he's the
governor we have color exactly but but
have you done advocacy or would
absolutely yeah no I I am very I'm
passionate about advocacy um so uh
around climate we're members of um
business businesses for Innovative
climate and energy policy which is a
part of series um around water I mean so
we trying to pick the issues that are
aligned so not like you're saying not
like access to Market really alcohol
beverage related but that are still
aligned with our in business interest um
we've been very active to um strengthen
and clarify ify the uh jurisdiction of
the Clean Water Act and pushing the
administration and the EPA to strengthen
and uh and kind of uh reverse uh Supreme
Court decisions that weaken the Clean
Water Act um is there fracking in
Colorado there is fracking in Colorado
there's a lot of oil and gas in Colorado
is is water contamination an issue that
that you've gotten involved in related
to
fracking our position on fracking is um
somewhat
nuanced by virtue that we depend on
natural gas to make beer and you know
you have to heat you have to make Steam
right to make beer and so I feel like it
would be disingenuine for us to be
against uh gas development unequivocally
because we depend on natural gas and we
also know that U making electricity with
natural gas seems to be although the
data is somewhat Squishy in different
areas but it seems to be um have has
less of a a climate impact than making
it out of coal so you know guess has
that advantage
um what I believe and what New Belgium
um the position that we take is that
that fracking is going is here to stay
so how can we regulate it to make it as
safe as possible to make it the least
impact on water the least impact on
local communities least impact on land
owners and so I think that Colorado
leads the nation in um you know
Progressive or St strong regulation
around fracking another one of those
complex sustainability issues that is
hard to distill into a single image in
an advertisement yeah exactly was there
another question I thought yeah hi I'm
Corey from the forestry school I just
want to go back to packaging real quick
um I know a lot of Brewers prefer to
package their beers and cans uh because
um because of claims that it preserves
the beer better but also that it uses
less resources in terms of um reducing
weight and transportation I was
wondering if New Belgium has done any
lcas in that regard to uh guide the way
way that it packages its beers yeah
absolutely we did do an LCA around uh
can can versus bottle in shorthand um
and the reason we did it is because we
were seeing a lot of claims by other
craft Brewers that it was a cans were
more sustainable package and then we had
people asking us because we have done
lcas before and we've been out in front
on these issues what was true and we
didn't know so we felt like we had to do
the LCA and it's very um for those of
you who have ever done an LCA the the
reliability of the data that you're
getting is questionable you can use the
very best data basis but you don't have
transparency into where they're getting
their data so I would never take an LCA
to the bank
um it's directional I think and it has
orders of magnitude impact and so when
you're looking at cans compared to
bottles um obviously box site mining is
hugely impactful and creates high hurdle
for the can to overcome throughout the
rest of its life cycle which it is able
to do so because of Transportation as
you said the lighter weight and shipping
um and then we found out another um
another thing that advantages the cam
but is certainly just a um a coincidence
as it were or not not a coincidence but
it's not intrinsic to the can is the
fact that aluminum smelters have cited
on hydro and get their electricity
provided by hydroelectric which makes
their electricity impact much less than
someone who is getting it off a cold
fired grid so bottom line they're not
real they're not massive advantages from
a at least from a CO2 emission
standpoint for either package and I
think the consumer should choose which
one is appropriate to their drinking
occasion and they're both they both have
their
place bottle or can
both and don't forget the keg and The
Keg right probably one of which is the
most right of course a
draft um other questions yeah when you
think about the kind of 5 to 10 seconds
you have when a consumer is scanning the
aisle and looking at a a bottle is there
any relevant Ecco Lael or signal that
you can send or you think or you guys
are going to think about testing that
could signal that sort of sustainability
and and you think there's actually a
reasonable sized percentage of the
market that's going to respond to that
you know is there a group of consumers
who actually care enough to see
something and is there something you can
put on there which will drive sales uh
in a way that's focused on
sustainability I don't you I wish you
would tell me what that that label would
be um you know I think that organ that
there are certainly consumers who are
more aware of what organic means and
probably look for that although it's not
that available all you know widely
available in beer um you know we have a
1% for the planet um logo but I think
it's on the bottom of our sixpack
carrier we have a BC Corp logo but I
think it's on the bottom of our sixpack
carrier so our position has been not to
clutter the aesthetic with certification
logos um so I guess the short answer is
yeah for us there has not been a silver
bullet for this means where AOK yeah
yeah it's interesting because there's
just a proliferation of those logos and
I'm sure I'm sure New Belgium is
involved in so many sustainability
related efforts that have logos that you
could probably have a can covered with
every logo except your own right true
and sometimes you see products like that
um other I think we have time for one or
two
more hi I'm Kenny I'm from the uh
forestry school uh talking about borp
and sort of the idea of certification it
seems to be that borp is starting to
grow as more of a leg legislative and
Regulatory way of doing business and
less so as just a like cold cut throw a
label on your bottle uh entity and what
do you how do you see New Belgium as
like building that community of B Corps
and growing because you mentioned craft
Brewers as sort of the ultimate
conscious consumer and opening that door
to getting other breweries into be
beneficial certification and how that
can help grow B Corp as a sort of way of
doing business yeah that's a great
question and when we first started
talking to the blab folks a few years
ago and they were saying this is our
this is how we imagine it and your
consumer will know you're not
greenwashing and you'll have a community
of people where you can share services
at a reduced cost and there's this
legislative piece and we kept bringing
like that's the piece that's interesting
that's what's new and unique that um
that be the beneficial designation is
unlike any other logo or certification
that you could get um so and yes so
that's why it's interesting to us and
that's why I think that it has real
gravitas around it because you're
actually changing your corporate bylaws
to say that you're going to be different
and we are in Colorado there the um blab
is open up an office to make Colorado
some one of the epicenters of the
movement and and certainly New Belgium
would be very interested in reaching out
to other craft Brewers who are
interested because I think like you said
they're already they're already almost
there J Jen you mentioned changing the
bylaws and for people who might not be
familiar with benefit Corp as a le as a
tax incorporation status what's the key
how is it different from other types of
incorporation so if you you have to be
in a state where it's been passed that
there exists this entity called benefit
you know benefit Corp so there's you're
still an S corp or a CP but doesn't
change your tax status in that way it
just says that for you to call yourself
a benefit corporation that you have to
put in your corporate charter that you
work towards a specific public benefit
so not just for the benefit of your um
shareholders but other stakeholders and
what it provides it provides actually
fiduciary cover for your board and for
your managers to make decisions that
aren't always preferential towards um
maximizing shareholder value so it's
moving it's actually moving from the
American model of shareholder capitalism
to a stakeholder model I think is super
exciting yeah potentially really
groundbreaking I know we have efforts in
dcn in Maryland to change yeah to to
create the legal status yeah and in
Delaware it it passed in Delaware last
year and Delaware is sort of the you
know the center of corporate law for the
United States so so do we have um flag
me if we're going to run over or should
we take one more from online or one more
okay anyone want the last
word or do you just want to get to the
happy
hour okay happy hour it is well thank
you all so much for coming and let's
thank Jen and Chris for leading us to a
really
great